These fingers with a delicious chip butty
The secret of a good chip butty is in the potato
Now these are désirée
potatoes one of my first ever jobs
Was working in a chip shop most input sacks and sacks of potatoes into the rumbler which will send the potato peeler
All day long today. I'm gonna do something a bit healthier for my oven chips with a twist
simply peel
slice and blanch for three to four minutes
drain
season and cover well with paprika
spread evenly over an oiled baking tray and
Place into a preheated oven for 20 minutes
simple as that
Next up easy fish fingers. This is Pollock a
Really nice firm delicious fish cut the fish and finger size patterns of fish
Put them onto your plate and just lightly salt them
You can do that literally 20 minutes 30 minutes before you start cooking the fish
It firms the fish up beautifully and it allows it to become a little more durable especially in the pan now for the coating
Start by thoroughly coating the fish in seasoned flour
And then just roll it
To get rid of those little sharp corners
Because then it stops those corners almost burning in the pan in to a wash
And really coat them
wonderful
Then this is dill goes running you out with a fish and run the deal through my breadcrumbs
That makes it more aromatic
Laman on to your breadcrumbs nothing wrong with the chip butty nothing wrong with fish fingers
Just give it a lovely modern twist
Beautiful once the fish fingers are thoroughly coated they're ready to pan fry, and they'll need around three minutes on each side
All the fish fingers to be nice and crispy get a really nice color on them first and then we'll flip them over
Then finish them with butter
Bring the heat up into the pan a nice little normal butter
That worked wonders with the bread comes in the deal
Nice and carefully
Take them out, they look and smell incredible
Stay nice and crispy
Now to assemble my chip butty starting with buttered thick crusty bread
It's nice and wet
Mop up that amazing flavor
On
Slice in half never slice in an angle
My mouth is salivating
beautiful
On with the chip butty, there's one thing missing and it signifies that I've never forgotten the joy
of comfort food, but my god that makes me feel like a nine-year-old
Excuse me for a moment, want to stuff my face
Homemade fish fingers and my ultimate chip butty so simple to make but trust me it tastes amazing
Now the secret to whisking is a big beautiful balloon whisk
the bigger the blue that needs sliding down
juicy and creamy tender